in the last video where we launched
something at an angle we figured out the
horizontal and the vertical components
of that launch velocity and we use a
vertical component to figure out how
long that thing is in the air and then
we use that time to figure out how far
it will travel given a constant
horizontal velocity what I want to do in
this video is to redo part of that
problem and I want to redo the part to
figure out how long this object stays in
the air and I'm going to do it in a
slightly more complicated way than the
way I did in the last video but it's
kind of a more powerful way and we'll
see that it's more powerful in more in
future videos so the last video to
figure out how long is in the air we
said look we're starting and stopping at
the same elevation whatever our vertical
velocity is here upward we're going to
have the same magnitude of velocity but
it's going to be downward we use that
insight to figure out the change in
velocity and then we use that change in
velocity and the constant acceleration
due to the force of gravity on an object
in freefall to figure out the time in
the air and it was pretty simple
mathematically what we're going to do
now is derive is to derive a a formula
that's useful in physics although I like
to always derive it from scratch and
that's what we're going to derive it
over here and you've seen me derive this
formula before but just to start off we
need to remind ourselves that the
vertical velocity that we calculated in
the last video was five meters per
second and given that vertical velocity
let's figure out how long this thing
stays in the air so our vertical
velocity our velocity in the Y direction
is five meters per second and also as a
reminder our convention when we're
dealing with vectors in one dimension
and this is essentially in one dimension
now since we know it's in the Y
direction it is positive means up
negative means down and we're dealing
with the vertical direction when we're
dealing with the horizontal direction
positive means to the right negative
means to the left so just to make sure
we have those conventions down so how
can we figure out how long this thing
stays in the air so we can remind
ourselves that the displacement and
everything we're talking about now is
well this will actually apply whether in
any one dimension but the displacement
is equal to the average velocity the
average average
the average velocity times our change in
time times the amount of time that's
elapsed and what is our average velocity
our average velocity is our if we assume
constant acceleration it is our final
velocity it is our final velocity plus
our initial velocity actually let me
write it this way it'll make it a little
bit cleaner it is our initial velocity
plus our final velocity divided by two
so literally the arithmetic mean of our
initial and final velocities and we're
going to multiply that times change in
time times change in time now what is
our final velocity going to be our final
velocity I'll write it over here our
final velocity your final velocity is
the same thing as your initial velocity
it's the same thing as your initial
velocity plus plus acceleration times
your cut plus your acceleration times
how much time has passed by
this right here is your final this right
here is your final velocity so let's
substitute that back into this right
over here and what do we get we get our
initial velocity so our average velocity
is now our initial velocity plus our
final velocity the final velocity is
this over here so it's our initial
velocity plus the acceleration times
times the amount of time that passes by
all of that divided by let me do that
same color all of that divided by two
all of that divided by two and all of
this is multiplied by the amount of time
that passes by once again this is our
total displacement so this this part
right over here get do it in magenta we
have to V is right so that simplifies to
two V is two times our initial
velocities and so this expression right
here simplifies to two times VI divided
by two is our initial velocity our
initial velocity and then we have and
then well I'll just do it all here and
then I'll multiply times the
elapsed after that plus plus the
acceleration times time the acceleration
times the amount of time that's passed
by divided by two and all of this is
multiplied by the amount of time that
passes by and this is our total
displacement and we're almost done and
if you are if you have to take a physics
exam under time pressure it's not
ridiculous to not have to read arrive it
every time but it's I it's I want to
emphasize it you should realize that
these these formulas come from almost
just common basic sense principles and
you should be able to derive them but
it's good to memorize them if you have a
time pressure exam so now if we multiply
this delta T you get the total
displacement is equal to your initial
velocity your initial velocity times
times your change in time plus I'll do
the same color plus your acceleration
over two times you have a delta T times
a delta T remember Delta just means
change in time this triangle just means
change in time so change in time times
change in time is change in time squared
change in time squared and this
expression right here this is in some
physics books or in some classes they'll
just give you this formula but I wanted
to show you that it's derived from very
very simple principles from just
displacement is average velocity times
time what is average velocity what is
final velocity is just initial velocity
plus acceleration times time and you'll
get this expression right over here so I
did this to figure out how much time
we're going to spend in the air so how
do we do that for this particular
problem well we know our initial
velocity that's the launch the vertical
component because we're dealing with
just a vertical component here we know
our initial velocity we know the
acceleration due to gravity and in this
situation we want to figure out when the
displacement is going to be and this is
going to be a little bit unintuitive but
hopefully that makes sense when the
displacement is going to be zero because
there's going to be two times when the
displacement is going to be zero there's
going to be the time right when we
launch it right at time zero the
displacements going to be zero then the
then this thing is going to go is going
to be launched and then come back to the
ground and then when it comes back to
the ground the displace what's going to
be at Z
again so if we've set if we set the
displacement to be equal to zero we
should get two answers to that and one
of them should have a non zero time
component one of them will probably be
zero and the other one will have a non
zero time and that's the one that we
should go for because that's the set
that's the second time that's the time
when we've hit the ground so let's apply
that so we have the displacement is
going to be zero so zero is equal to our
initial velocity is five meters per
second upwards I won't write the unit's
just for the sake of space five meters
per second upwards times change in time
times change in time plus what's our
acceleration well our convention is if
it's if something's going downwards if
the the one dimensional vector is going
downwards its negative so the
acceleration is negative 9.8 meters per
second squared you divide that by 2 so
we get actually let me just write it all
out 9 point actually let me write it
like this
it's negative 9.8 meters per second
squared I'm not writing the unit's here
just for simplicity just so that we
don't take up too much space times and
then all of this times delta T delta T
squared and lucky for us this one is
pretty simple we don't have to resort to
factoring or we will factor but we don't
resort to the quadratic formula or
anything like that to solve this
quadratic equation right over here we
can factor out a delta T so we get 0 is
equal to delta T times 5 minus 9.8 over
4 point two is four point nine four
point nine and if you factor out a delta
T out of delta T squared you're left
with another you're left with another
delta T so there's two solutions here
there's two ways to get there's two
Delta T's that'll give us zero either
this delta T is equal to zero so either
delta T is equal to zero that's just our
starting point so that's that's not the
time that we're interested in when no
time has passed by or or all of this
business could be equal to zero if we
have two things when I take their
product in equals zero that means either
one or both of them are equal to zero
so we have five minus 4.9 delta T 4.9
delta T is equal to zero is equal to
zero we could add 4.9 delta T to both
sides of this equation
and we will get 5 is equal to 4.9
delta-t 4.9 delta T delta T and then we
divide both sides by 4.9 we divide both
sides by 4.9 to get the alash elapsed
time so delta T is equal to five divided
by four point nine is we're at the home
stretch five divided by four point nine
is equal to one point zero two seconds
so it's equal to one point zero two
seconds and so once again we got the
same exact answer we got in the last one
we just used a different method and
that's one of the really fun things
about physics is as long as you're doing
logically consistent correct things
there's many ways to often get that
answer but it should be the same answer
if it's not you probably did something
wrong in one of those two ways of doing
it